put very simply we cannot go on as we
are
my laws we've therefore had to consider
all our options
in particular we have looked carefully
at the safeguards provided by article 16
of the protocol these exist to deal with
significant societal and economic
difficulties
as well as with trade diversion there
has been
significant disruption to east-west
trade a significant increase in trade on
the island of ireland
as companies change supply chains and
considerable disruption to everyday
lives
there has also been societal instability
seen most regrettably with the disorder
across northern ireland at
easter indeed the false but raw
perception in the unionist community of
separation from the rest of the united
kingdom
has had profound political consequences
these are very serious effects which
have put people
businesses and the institutions of the
belfast good friday agreement
under strain it is clear that the
circumstances exist
to justify the use of article 16.
nevertheless my lords we have concluded
that it's not the right moment
to do so instead we see an opportunity
to
proceed differently to find a new path
to seek to agree with the eu
through negotiations a new balance in
our arrangements covering northern
ireland
to the benefit of all and it's in that
spirit
that today's command paper outlines the
new balance
that we wish to find it is a balance
which needs to ensure that goods can
circulate much more freely within the uk
customs territory while ensuring that
full processes are applied to goods
destined for the eu
it's a balance which needs to enable all
in northern ireland
to continue to have normal access to
goods from the rest of the uk
by allowing goods meeting both uk and eu
standards
to circulate there and it is a balance
which needs to normalize the basis of
the protocols governance
so that the relationship between us and
the eu is
no longer policed by the eu institutions
and the court of justice
we should return to a normal treaty
framework similar to all our other
international agreements
that is more conducive to the sense of
genuine and
equitable partnership that we seek
of course we also recognize our share of
responsibility in helping the eu
protect its single market as part of
this we are willing to explore
exceptional arrangements around data
sharing and cooperation and penalties in
legislation to deter those looking to
move non-compliant products from
northern ireland to ireland
and i repeat all of this is entirely
consistent
with maintaining an open border without
infrastructural checks
between ireland and northern ireland
my lord these proposals will require
significant change to the northern
ireland protocol
we do not shy away from that we believe
such change is necessary
to deal with the situation we now face
we look to open a discussion on these
proposals urgently
at the same time we must provide
certainty and stability for businesses
as we do so
so we believe that we in the eu should
also quickly agree
a standstill period as it were including
maintaining the operation of great
appearance in force
and a freeze on existing legal actions
and processes
this is to ensure there is room to
negotiate and to provide a genuine
signal of good intent to find ways
forward
my lords the difficulties we have in
operating the northern ireland protocol
are now the main obstacle to building a
relationship with the eu
that reflects our strong common
interests and values
instead of that relationship we are
seeing one which is punctuated with
legal challenges
and characterized by disagreement and
mistrust
we do not want that pattern to be set
not least because it does not support
stability in northern ireland
it's now the time to work to establish a
new balance
which both the uk and eu can invest in
to provide a platform for peace and
prosperity in northern ireland
and to allow us to set out on a new path
of partnership
with the eu we have today in our command
paper set
out an approach which we believe can do
just that
we urge the eu to look at it with fresh
eyes and to work with us
to seize this opportunity and put our
relations on to a better footing
we stand ready to work with them to
deliver the brighter future
that is within reach